les amateurs de cyclisme seront
certainement sur le bord des routes
samedi et 2 mars jour de départ du
Paris-Nice la première course européenne
de la saison qui débute pour la
quatrième année consécutive dans les
Yvelines il y a tout ce qu'il faut pour
la pratique du cyclisme de la bicyclette
et du cyclisme dans le département des
Yvelines bien sûr pour le cycliste de
compétition et c'est pour ça que nous
revenons régulièrement
c'est la quatrième année et nous avons
déjà avec Alain Schmitz le président du
Conseil général des Yvelines signer une
convention pour quatre années
supplémentaires jusqu'en 2017 et un
partenariat département ASO à hauteur de
50000 euros pour ces quatre années 71e
édition donc du Parisis avec un prologue
très court depuis Houilles un prologue
2,9 km c'est le retour du prologue assez
court faudrait que je regarde dans les
annales parce que 2 km 900 c'est ça je
crois que ça fait depuis 2008 qu'on n'a
pas eu une cipline distance mais c'est
pas plus mal c'est une affaire d'autres
spécialistes c'est pas les spécialistes
du contre-la-montre c'est d'autres
spécialistes ça peut être des sprinters
parce qu'il y a pas mal de relance un
prologue le samedi et une première étape
le dimanche 3 mars devant le château de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye que l'on pourra
suivre aussi sur le service public il
est prévu sur France 3 le samedi
la compétition du samedi et celle du
dimanche une durée de diffusion d'une
heure 30 le samedi et 1h30 sur la fin de
la compétition le dimanche après-midi
sur France 3 national les Yvelines
département
s Nice en mars
et le 30 juillet Versailles accueillera
la dernière étape de la mythique course
la 100e édition du Tour avec le départ
de Versailles comme nous avions fait le
départ de Rambouillet pour la dernière
étape l'an dernier
des villes dans les Pyrénées ou dans les
Alpes accueille régulièrement le tour
des années de suite en région parisienne
c'est beaucoup plus rare voire rarissime
c'est parce qu'encore une fois nous
sommes bien et c'est vrai aussi que pour
nous quand vous partez de Rambouillet
quand vous partez de Versailles c'est
prestigieux c'est valorisant c'est
valorisant aussi pour nous et pour le
tour en général en attendant donc le
Tour de France en juillet les amateurs
pourront profiter du départ du 71e
Paris-Nice les deux et trois mars
prochain 166 coureurs engagés